Attentive because cases of pertussis soar
and a lot.
1 striking example
we find it in the Community of Madrid.
Throughout the past year,
only
8 cases and in 3/1 months of this 2,024,
The number of infections has already been recorded.
data are also of concern,
the last community to notify
this promotion.
We are talking about 7,230 infections.
In only 3/1 months of this year has it multiplied.
by 13!
The epidemic
affects
especially to children between 10 and 14 years of age.
Inés Valverde,
what's going on?
Yes,
it is a epidemic that occurs every 3 to 5 years.
It is similar to 1 cold that lasts 1 or 2 weeks.
who is followed by strong HUS attacks,
eh?
For the time being,
the following are being recorded here
especially between the ages of 10 and 14.
In in what VA of years have been recorded
15 admissions,
only 1 of them in the ICU
and from the Ministry of Health
insist that it is not getting tense
the health system,
but the experts
emphasize the importance of getting vaccinated.
every time it is our turn